[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i did dmt three times in a day wow the
the third time it was a really strong
one
and um why'd you do it three times in a
day were you trying to do that on
purpose or were you guys
the first time was light i went in but i
didn't go in too deep yeah but i saw the
visuals and i laid there and i was like
i got to the door and i could see
through the windows of the house but i
didn't go inside the second time it just
like opened up a [ __ ] vortex and
sucked me through to the center of the
universe and then it was really really
really intense and then i did it again
after that because i loved it because it
was so awesome i wanted to do it one
more time one time recently i did like
the last time i did was a couple years
ago i opened my eyes in the middle of it
it was very strange so i can almost see
reality but it was all real pixelated
and it was like i was seeing life
through like
a dirty saran wrap or something it was
all was just very strange and then i
closed my eyes back and i went it's the
the the experience of the psychedelic
realm is more vivid than regular life
which is real strange
because it doesn't feel like you're on a
drug
because you're still you that's another
part of it it doesn't change your like
when you're drunk it changes the way you
think like you think different this is
not that this is like you think the same
way but you're being confronted with
something that's
insanely alien just alien to everything
that you know to be true and then
there's all these things around you that
seem to be alive and they seem to be
talking to you and communicating either
what did it make you feel
like i knew nothing
that was the most profound aspect like
all of this stuff that you concentrate
on every day is nonsense and there is
some other thing that's connected that's
probably influencing this world yeah and
it's probably what what people see when
they have near-death experiences the
depictions of the afterlife i mean
that's probably what it all is and
religious experiences and when prophets
are talking about oh my god i went into
this realm there's these beings they've
told me we're all one we have to
scholars in jerusalem are connecting
moses's experience with the burning bush
to the acacia tree the acacia tree which
is rich in dmt the burning bush is what
god was to moses and that through this
burning bush he came out with these ten
commandments of how people should live
their lives i mean that easily could
have been
just a very convoluted
sort of translation of a dmt trip
certainly and also when you think of
certainly there are archetypal images
that seem to be repeated throughout
ancient cultures and archaic stories
that seem to refer to the potential for
plant experiences to affect
consciousness even the garden of eden do
not eat of the fruit of the tree of
knowledge otherwise you will become as
god predominantly you have five
immunodmt which is
likely the strongest naturally occurring
serotonergic psychedelic and
for conservation purposes it's necessary
that people stop milking toads because
it's become too popular mike tyson's
talking about it all the time
i i made i mean and it's like it sounds
ridiculous like mike tyson could have an
effect on um
conservation and then why would they go
to scenarios when they find these toads
yeah
yeah i've never experienced it from the
toad i've only watched them
with the way they extract yeah they grab
them and they squeeze it and bust those
pimples and then bust it on a glass of
mirror and then take it off and they let
it harden yeah they they let it dry in
the sun they scrape it off with a razor
blade yeah i've only had it uh
synthetically made in a laboratory you
should be able to buy it online used to
be able to it was legal recently 2011
jug of this [ __ ] oh my god offline uh i
bought it from some company american
chemical company or something and they
send it to you and i had enough to get
the entire state of california high for
several days i never felt the thing that
felt so much like not making me
hallucinate but like it was taking away
a hallucination yes and that is such
there's something so terrifying about
that but also like wow that's great like
right and uh
you just you feel like there has to be
just based on the [ __ ] you would see
even if it's just [ __ ] in your head
you're like why would that even be in my
head it's it's entirely possible that
whatever the [ __ ] consciousness is can
pass from this stage into another stage
and the only reason why i would hesitate
to say that's exactly what happens is
because there's no proof one way or
another but it's it's all that pioneer
gland [ __ ] is not proven they don't know
that dmt comes out they can't handle
that anymore no they don't know yeah
they do
yeah the cottonwood research foundation
they did a a series of tests with rats
and they proved that live rats have uh
dmt produced by the pineal gland no it
doesn't necessarily mean that humans do
too but they're pretty sure they did you
like they also know that your your lungs
produce it and your liver produces it
that's a fact really yeah so your body
is producing damp tape 100 i'm trying to
explain things that are not possible to
explain because the words that we're
using were all invented for a world that
doesn't exist in the dmt dimension and
once once you break through it is so
profoundly alien that anywhere
liberating yes yeah well in a way i mean
it made me really truly realize that we
are in a soup of of atoms and that it's
not yeah there's not like michael pollan
joe rogan and jamie vernon in a room
here's a wood table there's oxygen in
between right no this that we're in a a
universal stew yeah diffused particles
yeah and it breaks those
particles down or at least it gives you
a view into that and you cease to exist
which is the most bizarre thing because
it's so similar to n and
dimethyltryptamine chemically but so
different in experience the fact that
you're not there most people smoke dmt
they do this they smoke it and they just
go
and they lay back and then this this
overwhelming experience happens to them
for like 15 minutes and then they come
back that's it and they they come back
yeah they don't move they just it's not
hours no no no it's a quick experience
ayahuasca is an orally active experience
with dmt what ayahuasca is
when you
if you tried to eat dmt dmt is broken
down in your gut by something called
monoamine oxidase i'll tell you the
thing that just sticks with me that i'm
like how in the [ __ ] is that possible is
the shapes that you that i i could see
or i was well aware that they were a bit
more than three-dimensional
shapes
and i it's so crazy to look at that and
perceive it and i'm like how on earth
could i perceive this shape and when i
can't and you can't come back with it
like you know you know how you see it
though in someone's art like have you
ever seen alex gray's art yeah you see
he's awesome no you haven't seen it no
what is it pull up uh alex gray he's a
psychedelic artist i mean all of his
stuff is basically trying to mean based
art is it gonna not be worshipped
because sometimes no no no no no he's
brilliant his stuff's [ __ ] that is
something he's his stuff's [ __ ]
amazing oh yeah that thing for two years
that's one of them but yeah he draws uh
the uh covers for tool albums there's a
ton of them like that one down
specifically that's dmt that's that's
that is dmt wow that is hardcore dmt
hardcore dmt when you do dmt you see
that and you see that in a way where
it's so much more spectacular than any
anything you ever see is your normal
consciousness is your body there like
are you like not a body thing you're not
thinking about yourself you're so close
i mean i'm myself yeah you're you're
like you look around you're you're dude
if you open your eyes
here's what's crazy because you so if
you close your eyes it's like they're
open somewhere else
and then you open your eyes you see
reality overlaid over there tell me this
one shouldn't influence the egyptians
click on the one your cursor's on no i
tell me that didn't influence the
egyptians what this painting or the this
this these kind of tripped well did they
have images did they have dmt 100 yeah
there was one of the things that john
anthony west did was uh he was going
over that temple in man the temple in
man is one of the structures it's in um
in uh egypt and it it shows different
parts of it are supposed to represent
different corridors of the body like
different chakras of the body
and that there was some evidence that
the eye of horus is really the pineal
gland i see so much more humanity in
everyone i'm around like i feel very
changed after doing dmt it's a very
profound experience and like i'm just
noticing more things about people i'm
being more aware of like their body
language when they talk to me and
it's
i think it was a very positive thing
doing dmt and my experience was the
closest thing to
a spiritual experience i've ever had
because i've never been a person that's
been terribly connected to like
anything larger than me i've never been
religious never been spiritual and i'd
say it was the closest to like a
spiritual
thing for me i think it is a spiritual
thing i think it's an undeniably
spiritual thing that's the thing about
it is that it forces you
to think about
love and connection and then the bonds
that people have with each other in a
way that you don't get from anything
else the the the the powerful experience
of a transcendent psychedelic moment
is uh it's not like anything else you
experience in life other than maybe like
a near-death experience
but you could argue that they're the
same thing i know people that have had
near-death experiences that swear that
it was like a dmt trip i'm sure and
there i think i don't think it's
confirmed but people say that it's what
happens when you
legally die or medically die it's like
you have a dmt trip and i could see that
but it's not confirmed but there's a lot
of in you know there's a lot of evidence
that points to that kid cudi been in
here and kid cudi's had some psychedelic
experiences yeah once you go there's
just um you don't want to do nothing
else again
well it puts it all in the perspective
it lets you see that uh as much as this
thing seems to be important this is all
temporary and you're a part of forever
and it also allows you to become
comfortable with death yeah
yeah you know who said that larry hagman
he sprung it on him on cnn once he was
talking about how he did acid he took a
big dose of acid and he's never worried
about death ever again that it just
alleviated his his worry about passing
on
that's why this is actually i felt the
same way and i said well it doesn't
matter anymore yeah i think dnt even
more specifically because they think
yeah why don't they affect the mind that
way what causes to affect the mind that
way they don't totally know that it
makes a good visioning you know you
visualize everything you know once i did
i wanted to do it again and again and
again and they said you shouldn't do it
too much mike wait i gotta you know
grasp what's going on here why am i
feeling this why why did this in a weird
way like humbled you i don't think you
should listen to the people so you
shouldn't do it too much i think you
should do it as much as you want that's
what i agree with too yeah i agree you
could handle it if you could end up
being like tyson you can handle doing
dmt issues
yeah that's where i think i'm going i
think i'm going in that direction best
of that ever if you like this video i
want to see more funny comedians we're
featuring a new up and coming comic on
our instagram every single day go check
it out right now link and bye we're
saying everyone these free stickers that
enjoyment
is a you know that's enough it doesn't
have to be some lofty ass [ __ ] it's just
like people get a little like
this tiny little smell of heaven
like a better place a lighter place a
place that isn't encumbered by so much
[ __ ] is this particular realm that
can like completely take someone out of
a depression man that can completely
give somebody the you know juice they
need to like get back out there and like
open up themselves to the world and not
be shut down just one little like tiny
tiny minuscule reminder of like don't
worry there's this isn't the only place
there's simultaneously
amazing things happen
happening which you're part of you just
don't realize it yet and
don't worry there's all these entities
that are trying to calm you down relax
relax take it in settle down settle down
they're all trying to calm you down and
and and alleviate yeah it's it's it's
weird do you ever look at somebody while
you're on youtube
no i've always kept my eyes closed okay
two times close my eyes and one time
over my eyes and look at somebody and
they had six arms like a hindu yeah
somebody else just was just saying i
might have been telling you this at the
comedy store told me at the the green
room what is it your time perception
gets broken down and that's the
craziness and so
then motion looks like sick like it's
like shiva it looked like a hindu thing
and i'm like wow i imagine beyond that
stuff and you see something i mean it
looked that looked to me so much like a
vision from the entity those six armed
kind of guys dude i collect that kind of
art like buddhas and [ __ ] like that like
this kind of [ __ ]
because i saw this i saw this image this
exact image i mean this has a
third eye and everything the sculptor
made this for me what i described is
complex geometric patterns that are made
out of love and understanding they they
seem to me to be like the building
blocks of the soul all around you all
the time some just gigantic
impossibly large infinite
well of souls just these things dancing
around you and they were they were never
one thing they would be one thing for a
second and they change into something
else and they change it to something
different and the more profound the
experiences got the more profound the
next one would be and they kept saying
like look at this look at this like but
the words weren't real words that's the
other thing it's like i'm saying the
words look at this and i would have that
in my head but i never heard anybody say
it it was almost like it was triggering
those the the concept of those words in
my mind the one drug where i feel like
when i took it i wasn't there anymore i
i was gone until i came back like i i
felt like i didn't have thoughts i
didn't have
i i knew i knew i was experiencing
the 5vo dmt realm or whatever it was
but i didn't there was no
context
in terms of i didn't realize i'm on my
couch sitting at home like i was gone i
was gone there's no visuals it was just
this
white
sort of pixelated
like grayish white gone world
you know and it was terrifying because
it felt like death it was the one thing
that felt the most like
oh my god like now now i don't know i'm
not here anymore
but
coming back from it i think it was very
valuable now they're assuming that human
beings also produce it in the pineal
gland which would you know it kind of
sort of verifies what everybody always
thought the pineal gland is they thought
they would call it the seed of the soul
that this is where
your your journey to the afterlife
begins in the pineal gland and that this
chemical gateway opens up and your soul
passes through to the great beyond dmt
is interesting in that first of all it's
very quick the experience is only about
15 minutes 20 minutes max and it's also
it's not necessary
it's not intoxicant in the way that you
would think about traditional you are
still you in in the face of this
experience and i think
i think it's some sort of a chemical
gateway that's what i think i think
there's a gateway in your mind that can
lead to
some other dimension that's probably
there all the time if there is a uh
omnipresent continually existing realm
that human beings aren't accessing
because of the particular biochemical
formulation of consciousness as it is in
this point in our evolution yeah and
that we can get there and it seems as
like you know i've heard teres mckenna
say it's more real you know it's more
real there's stuff in there yes you know
and
excuse me and when he talks about them
beings you know like that he describes
himself dribbling basketballs creating
like faberge egg like you know
devices through vibration
i never saw him i would i want him he's
called the machine elves he's called
them all sorts of different things the
way i've described them is they're the
geometric patterns made out of love and
understanding i drew a shitty diagram of
it but this is what i thought this is
what it feels like if you ever do it
like this little point let's say this
little point is you this is what i felt
like and these lines i drew that's like
space and you're this little point that
gets stabbed into space time and all
this [ __ ] this is all the [ __ ] that
makes you like it forms a point it's
like closing your eyes and looking at
all of yeah all of the [ __ ] there's been
a cross-section of your being like
everything being focused into making if
you could like just reverse look at it
like that i always feel like it's
lessons i always feel like it's lessons
i always feel like it's time to go to
school sit down sit down here's what's
going on the one of the last ones more
profound ones was a bunch of jesters
that were all giving me the finger
really they were all circuit around me
like give me the finger like who named
you that was twitter
no you don't want to teach you about
twitter it's teaching
if you're intense if you're tense 60
years
giving you the finger like how do you
feel of yourself are you in constant
defensive mode and then when i sort of
relaxed myself they they started wagging
their finger back and forth like yep
that's it that's it that's
very very strange the the the these
things that you see but you can't define
are constantly changing so if you try to
like say oh it looked like a gesture it
probably did for a few seconds for a few
seconds it looked like a gesture and
then it imploded and became stars and
then it sucked in and became geometric
patterns and then became neon colored
worms that were making love to each
other and a giant infinite bundle of
yarn like it becomes weirder and weirder
[ __ ] all the time is it hard to remember
when you're done it's almost impossible
even me saying i'm kind of full of [ __ ]
it's having kind of full [ __ ] because i
don't totally remember what i saw i
remember what i remember to write down i
remember what i repeated so i'm like
going back on like my repeated versions
of what i saw but i just i remember like
flashes of the intense profound nature
of the experience i can't imagine after
now doing dmt twice i can't imagine
someone becoming like addicted to it oh
i wouldn't know about that i know a guy
was a tattoo artist that was doing dmt
every [ __ ] day multiple times a day
and then finally the entities had to sit
him down and go hey [ __ ]
stop stop like you're gonna lose your
grip on this world wow yeah they
literally literally told him to stop
doing it he said people know that i've
done a lot of psychedelic drugs so i'll
run into people
that know and they've done it too and
they look at you and they'll talk to you
like hey man you know i did this because
of you like a buddy of mine said that to
me the other day
you gave me the courage to try this
psychedelic truck and i was like oh [ __ ]
what was it like he said what did he
take he took dmt and he's like
that's a little bit more advanced i
would imagine
when this guy's a he's a bad
[ __ ] he's a navy ceo and
but never had any experience like that
didn't need
what was his experience with it
when everybody does it
you what you get when they're describing
it is just sort of like trying to use
words to describe something where
there's no references it's not the words
don't work you like you could kind of
tell me what it was like and i could
kind of go yeah okay i kind of see that
because i've done it but if i did if i
hadn't done it there's no way i've known
i have nothing that's like somebody
trying to explain their dream to you
well that's what's similar in that
this stuff dmt is actually endogenous it
exists in the human body and they
believe that it comes out in your dreams
they believe that when you're dreaming
your body is releasing some of that
stuff the cottonwood research foundation
which is uh connected to
rick strassman who wrote that book
dmt the spirit molecule he ran a bunch
of fda approved i think i believe the
only fda approved uh tests on dmt where
they shot it into people in um
a clinical setting how did you consume
freebasing it you freebase it
really yeah like a fiend yeah like a
fiend it's like a glass bowl connected
to like a tube
and you light the bottom of the bowl the
dmt sits inside what is the
looks like a white powder like a white
almost yellowish white powder depending
on which one you take the five methoxy
dmt is white and then the other stuff
was more like
white with like a little bit of yellow
to it and you take it it tastes like
burnt plastic it tastes terrible and you
take a big deep breath you want to take
like three big inhales the first time i
did it only took one and i just got to
the door i got like to the door of the
dmt dimension i was like what is this
weird it was really weird but i didn't
even know what weird was because like 20
minutes later i did a second one and the
second one i took way more i took like
three big hits and then it was almost
like you're in a slingshot or a catapult
it was like you could feel the tension
like dick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick and all
sudden
shot through these
colors and lights into like what felt
like
some new place that enjoyment is a you
know that's enough it doesn't have to be
some lofty ass [ __ ] it's just like
people get a little like
this tiny little smell of heaven
like a better place a lighter place a
place that isn't encumbered by so much
[ __ ] is this particular realm that
can like completely take someone out of
a depression man that can completely
give somebody the you know juice they
need to like get back out there and like
open up themselves to the world and not
be shut down just one little like tiny
tiny minuscule reminder of like don't
worry there's this isn't the only place
there's simultaneously
amazing things happen
happening which you're part of you just
don't realize it yet and
don't worry there's all these entities
they're trying to calm you down relax
relax take it in settle down settle down
they're all trying to calm you down and
and and alleviate yeah it's it's
it's weird when i first
was hitting it and then like you start
to leave the planet i felt like this
intense like
set of rings going around my body like
of just warmth and like happiness and
love and then all of a sudden i'm like
in space
and
um and i did see an elf which is what
people call them what they look like um
kind of like a court jester and it had
like slinky
long arms
and it would and it sounds like
crackhead [ __ ] if you've never done
d.o.t no i don't know
a lot of people have a shared like
physical description of what these
things look like one of my most profound
experiences i there was a bunch of court
jesters give me the finger
just flipping you off they're like [ __ ]
you
like i'm openly mocking me and i was
like what killing your ego
well i realize i take myself too
seriously like as they were doing i was
like i know what you're saying and they
went like this
like chill out that's it i like i got it
like while they were doing i was like oh
i get it i get it yeah
what's your opinion of it now
as like uh you know what you're seeing
well it could be anything i mean it
definitely could be some sort of an
insane
hijacking of your sensory nervous system
and it produces this spectacular
psychedelic effect that's so profound
this hallucinogen hallucinogenic effect
that's so profound that it literally is
like a transcendent experience and
changes your life it's something like
that to me it's totally possible that
it's just a chemical thing what's also
but that's also it's also possible is
that life itself that whatever the [ __ ]
life is and especially whatever the [ __ ]
intelligent life is is not understood
what consciousness is is not understood
and this idea that things can only exist
in this realm that's not proven also the
fact that when those quantum physicist
guys start breaking down the nature of
reality and they come up with i don't
know how the [ __ ] they do this i'm just
talking on my ass but they come up with
the idea that there's 11 dimensions
right and that they literally i mean and
this is all changing and constantly
evolving and moving and they're
constantly adding to this it is entirely
possible that there's a bunch of other
[ __ ] that's around us all the time
that's just not here and we don't have
access to it and when you do dmt
you go into that other place that's
what's so [ __ ] unsettling dude it's
like it's not like you're going it's
like the shit's here it's very bizarre
that it's so there it's so easy to get
to it's just 15 seconds away
it's one of the most insane experiences
that a human being could possibly
encounter yeah it's
if that was a if there was a thing that
you could like a ride at disneyland it
would be a mile long
mile long line to get into that [ __ ]
thing right everybody would be like i
want to go on that ride right because
it's so [ __ ] crazy for sure you learn
a lot about yourself when you do those
experiences i learned a lot about myself
learned a lot about how i interact with
people i saw negative thoughts like
expressed as like this dark green and
black like twisted sort of pattern and
then when my thoughts went positive it
blossomed like the most beautiful
flowers you can imagine it was crazy it
was literally a lesson in thinking
toxically and then and this is probably
like 2008 ish somewhere around then that
that was this particular experience that
literally changed who i am literally
changed how i talk to people literally
change how i feel about people watching
a negative thought being expressed as
this dark pattern right and then the
positive thought just i just let it go
like oh i see i see i'm doing it to
myself then boom right yeah and then you
just relax and enjoy like this is so
beautiful and because you're looking at
something so beautiful that feeling of
seeing beauty makes it more beautiful
and just getting more and like tears are
rolling down my eyes it was a stunning
stunning experience dude i was a god
it's easy to do that now besides that
but i i know what you mean i wish i
could remember seeing it though i
remember it happened and i remember the
dark green and black but it's so i
remember so little of what i actually
saw it's a total recreation in my mind
yeah one of the things about tryptamine
experiences is that things twist and
change and morph and shift and never
they never stay any one thing for any
length of time they're always becoming
other things and moving in and out of
things
like
[Music]
maybe that's just what happens over
there maybe these things are constantly
shifting and changing
you know maybe what we're doing is we're
trying to apply
when we think of how we are here in this
this life we're trying to apply those
laws
to whatever we experience when we when
we when we do that
but it seems so alien
when you have those experiences it seems
so alien you're not going to be able to
bring any of that back you can give
someone like little glimpses yeah and
what alex has done the best is capture
like oh i know what he's doing like
those faces those like almost egyptian
looking golden faces are moving and
apart from each other like you go oh
yeah i've seen something yeah something
sort of yeah there's a trip to mean part
to that yeah but that whatever that
would it be in that dimension it would
change and become something else and
instantaneously and then become
something else and then and a lot of it
has to do with how you're thinking
which is weird it's like are
is the way you're thinking actually
affecting those things
or is the way you're thinking and
affecting your perception
of whatever this energy is and how it
manifests itself visually well i mean
this is that right even in in what
you're saying there's this assumption
that that
your thinking is separate from the thing
right right right and and so
so we have a thought
and we're thinking to ourselves oh i
just got a good idea we don't know that
if we had a different way of quantifying
time and space we might have just seen
some ethereal miss drift through us that
produced a thing we called a thought
that we thought must be us so you look
at a thing in that realm and it's
shifting and converting and and you
notice that that conversion seems to be
happening in relation to like how you're
feeling and you know now you're in a
chicken or the egg
conversation which is like who's
you know who's reflecting who here
like
who
which of us is like real and which of us
isn't and or are we just kind of am i
just seeing who i actually am but
because i live in a world of um
individuality and i live in a world
where there's a separate quality to
things i see i have to see you as
separate because if i don't i can't see
you look listen i'm meditating the whole
like i meditate a lot i'm doing all
these things i'm experiencing
transcendent states i'm experiencing
what it's like to not feel attached to
my identity as russell who are you
before you are russell who are you
before you identify
yourself as a man in england who are you
who is the person who is the
consciousness who is the awareness now
when i listen to say terence mckenna
talking about his experiences in
psychedelia at such length and with such
lucidity and with so many philosophical
connotations and the way that he uses
the information he's getting from
hallucigenics
experiences to speculate on how we
should organize society
what the implications are for freedom
his refusal to accept that there are
certain kind of experiences that should
be prohibited that it's ridiculous that
adults should be prevented from having
that i i'm fascinated but i'm also i
suppose part of my bias is i love
anything that gets me out of my head i
feel a tremendous sense of relief
whether it's through meditation or even
sport
or sex being relieved of the burden of
the constantly thinking mind but when i
hear like those um vivid ex descriptions
of dmt realm or west correct i think
something in me hungers for that i've
never felt anything like that before no
nothing like that makes me not want to
do anything nothing else can supersede
that
how long ago did it happen
around two months ago yeah
did you write down what happened after
it happened or did you record it no i
wish i did yeah i wish it did yeah me
too if like it goes away like a dream
right
it comes off you know you're so scared
you know it's not stuff like this to me
like no no no no
that's not stuff no i don't wanna be
this i said hey i want this to stop now
the guy was like hey you're on the ride
and i'm like no no no yeah i love it i
love you i love you i love you yeah you
love everybody yeah so spast out
yeah
did you have a hard time letting go
at the beginning i was fighting it i was
saying stop i wanted to stop now just
jump stop this [ __ ] now
stop and the guy was like hey this is
like i can't do it gotta go for the ride
dude
and it was like oh man it's like i'm
dying things are going to myself i'm
seeing the aztec things i'm seeing told
i've been seeing weird animals and
things like this flying it's just it's
like another chamber it's boom flashing
yeah
yeah you're gone it's like rock are you
taking off
yeah it's beyond your imagination i you
know you take like one puff and before
you exhale um
i was i mean there's a synthetic version
too right i was taking the venom um
you're shot out of a cannon there's no
lead-up it's no warm-up he's like
and i felt like i was actually like
strapped to the outside of a rocket you
know going through space and through
clouds and like the g-horse was pulling
down my cheeks and it was just this
mental storm yeah without any
nothing to orient myself there was no
space there was no time there was no
self
and um
it was just unendurable this punishing
roar in my ears and someone who had done
it said eventually it's like a takeoff
and you get into orbit and it and it's
it's very nice at that point but what
happened with me is i had the
i had the storm i mean i felt like it
was like
the metaphor i used in the book is like
i said i can't explain this you can't
tell a story without place time and
character right i had none of those
right um
it was just this encoed energy and i
said it was it was like the before the
big bang you remember that well
obviously nobody does but but there was
pure energy and no matter yet and no
time yet i mean that's where i was
and um it was horrible it was terrifying
and i thought i was dying but then you i
you come down as kind of a suborbital
flight and and then i started coming
down and suddenly i could feel oh i got
a body you know i was touching my legs i
have a body and like oh there's a
there's a floor there's there's space
and then there's time and and the
universe kind of reconsolidated and i
had this feeling of incredible
gratitude yeah not just for being alive
which all of us have had at one point or
another but that anything existed i was
i was grateful for the fact that there
is something and not nothing because i
had seen what nothing was like
and so in that sense it ended up kind of
positive but you wouldn't want to go
there to have that experience so
subsequently somebody said to me a very
experienced psychonaut who i was telling
the story to he said you didn't have
enough
that's what i was just going to tell you
really yeah because you only took one
hit you usually take three you take
three and the rocket lie the rocket ride
leads you somewhere it takes you to the
seat you take three three three three
three in a row take the same time blow
it out take a big one blow it out take a
big one and as you're taking the third
one you're already seeing the world
crystallize in front of you it already
starts turning into geometric patterns
you put the pipe down lay back in the
chair and
just shoot off to the center of the
universe
the terrifying thing is you cease to
exist like yeah it's the one drug that
i've ever taken where you don't you're
not there anymore
uh even nn dimethyltryptamine which is
the difference between five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine is just an oxygen
oxygen molecule attached to it but nn
dimethyltryptamine is incredibly
visually stimulating
five methoxy is not yeah it's just white
inspiration or art or whatever the name
is you want to give it but it's really
it's like output from a place that maybe
is you know a flu a few floors up from
the one we're at it's having a pretty
wonderful party right now and like part
of what we do is like allow it to drip
into this realm which is potentially a
denser realm we're in the realm of
matter it's dense you know and like
ideas if you look at your ideas they're
they're light they're like they're
they're they're they don't have at least
my ideas like they're they're not like
heavy they're uh inspiration feels like
barely anything in fact it's so barely
anything think how easy it is to miss a
good idea how easy it is to think
something cool that maybe you want to
write down for a joke and you're just
i'll write that down later and then it's
gone it's light you can learn a lot from
it it's and it's it's very beneficial
and very strange that it's illegal you
know that it's illegal yeah i noticed
that even though like terence mckenna
had a joke about it because your body's
making it so everybody's holding
we all have it
you know it's illegal but it's like
making blood illegal now if
if there is some realm that we can reach
through that experience that scene that
puts into perspective everything that
else we experience on the material realm
and that thing seems to in your words be
emanating love and understanding while
ever changing completely formless and
communicating love and understanding
it for i can't help but think that that
should become
our priority to have a relationship with
that realm and to bring about that
experience i don't even mean in a
literal way because even terence mckenna
said there were some people
vulnerable souls he was probably
referring to people like me i think if
we lived in a healthy world uh a healthy
civilization that had a healthy
relationship with psychoactive
substances we'd probably have centers
where you would have a legitimate shaman
a medical advisor and someone would take
you through a guided experience [ __ ]
frog spit
[Music]
you